Elon on Twitter yeah what do you think  free speech is back as long as you don't  make fun of me didn't what was going on  with the impersonation stuff or like he  was like unless people explicitly Say  parody and their username I will suspend  those accounts ah I see you're gonna pay  for the check  I don't I don't know I don't think so  you know what [ __ ] it I'm gonna pay for  it because like are you even a real  person without a blue check no yeah  that's like kind of the point is that it  like encourages people to be like I'm  not a bot look at me okay then how will  everyone know that I'm better than them  see that I don't know yeah they need to  figure that out they need a super check  they they need one of those the check is  just gets more Caked Up Yeah the more  you pay this is a sexualized just like  humanoid yeah you can't tell what gender  it is it just has a fat [ __ ] ass  exactly damn this check mark is fat  how much are you pay ing for Twitter